[Musique]
non
françaises français en tant que
président de mon département
je visitais ya quelques heures un foyer
d'enfants abandonnés et en croisant
leurs regards de détresse je me disais
au fond une société qui tient debout
site une société qui met au premier plan
l'éducation dans la famille le respect
d'autrui le respect des plus anciens et
puis tout ce qui tourne autour de la
famille les médecins de famille la
responsabilité personnelle tout ce qui
fait une société chaude une société
chaleureuse je suis mère de famille de
quatre enfants il ya quelques années
j'ai fait le choix d'élever mes enfants
malheureusement le statut de mère au
foyer n'est pas reconnu à ce jour
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais le
salaire parental
qu'en pensez vous et que comptez vous
faire et bien moi je propose le salaire
familial et plus généralement une grande
politique familiale grande politique de
justice familiale une nouvelle politique
de justice familiale avec le salaire
familial pour les familles qui ont des
enfants ou qui choisissent de le garder
au domicile au foyer le grand père la
grand-mère face ou l'éducation ces
échanges de regards entre l'expérience d
un enthousiasme des plus jeunes
il faut aussi parler de la retraite des
mères de famille de manière qui est un
véritable statut familial et qu'on
reconnaisse la mission de service public
de l'éducation
c'est de cette manière que tournant la
société vers les plus petits car les
plus anciens on recréera une
civilisation du respect d'autrui
tourné vers la vie tournait à l'avenir
[Musique]
en tant qu'ancien combattant nous avons
rendu de nombreux services à la nation
et aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
reconnus à propos de cette retraite
je suis inquiet qui va payer notre
retraite et celle de nos enfants
justement je voudrais dire une chose
très simple ce qui peut pas y avoir de
retraite décente s'il n'y a pas de mains
des enfants c'est-à-dire des actifs
cotisants c'est à dire une grande
politique familiale c'est simple mais
encore faut-il le répéter
moi je veux une retraite décente pour
les anciens combattants parce qu'ils
sont mérité de la patrie c'est une
question de justice
une retraite équitable pour les artisans
pour les commerçants pour les
agriculteurs
souvent ils ont une retraite inférieure
ou rmi ch et puis il faut penser au
maintien à domicile moi je propose la
location dépendance c'est-à-dire la
possibilité pour les personnes âgées de
rester le plus longtemps possible à leur
domicile en créant notamment des postes
10000 postes d'infirmières libérales en
mettant fin à un certain nombre de
gaspillage de la sécurité sociale la
première qualité d'une société c'est
leur aspect des plus anciens d'entre
nous
[Musique]
en tant que médecin ce qui me préoccupe
c'est que sous couvert de vouloir
juguler les déficits de la sécurité
sociale
nous sommes amenés à porter un énorme
préjudice à la qualité des soins dont le
patient va être le premier à en subir
les conséquences
nous avons encore en france aujourd'hui
le meilleur système de santé du monde
il est menacé par la bureaucratie nous
avons encore un haut niveau de
protection sociale
il est menacée par bruxelles alors moi
je ne veux pas que bruxelles que les
bureaucrates les technocrates se
comporte avec les médecins commission
comporter avec les paysans des quotas
laitiers des quotas qui touche à la
liberté de prescription médicale moi je
suis attaché à la liberté de la médecine
libérale
c'est à dire la liberté les médecins il
faut faire confiance aux médecins et si
on veut sauver le système de protection
sociale le système de santé
il faut faire des économies moi je veux
rendre la sécurité sociale aux français
rendre la sécurité sociale aux assurés
sociaux pour contrôler les dépenses et
taxer les importations sauvages des pays
qui n'ont pas de protection sociale si
nous voulons demain avoir encore une
protection sociale il faut accepter un
minimum de protection économique
[Musique]
si je suis élu président la république
j'oserais faire ce que personne n'a osé
faire
je mettrai au pas des technocrates de
bruxelles
je leur expliquerai que la france compte
en faire respecter la liberté du peuple
français pour protéger nos emplois et
pour garantir notre liberté de décision
dans notre vie quotidienne
je suis agriculteur depuis 31 ans il ya
trois ans la communauté européenne ou
donner des subventions pour planter les
pommiers aujourd'hui on ne relevait
subventions pour les arracher tout cela
n'est que le résultat des accords du
gatt ainsi temps bénis l'hectare sont
arrachées ces vingt dix emplois
supprimés en contrepartie nous recevoir
6 hamilton le pommeau en provenance du
chili d'argentine à l'afrique du sud il
y a quelques jours dans le tarn et
garonne un spectacle de désolation
regardez cette pomme elle provient d'un
pommier du tarn et garonne qui a été
arrachée sur ordre les technocrates de
bruxelles que 25 militaires en europe
alors que le même pommier avaient été
plantés avec des subventions sera hors
de bruxelles
alors je suis allé à la grande surface à
quatre kilomètres de l'endroit où ce
premier avait été arrachée je
m'attendais à trouver des pommes du tarn
et garonne et qu'est ce que j'ai trouvé
cette pomme sur les étagères c'est à
dire une pomme en provenance du chili
en d'autres termes nous arrachons en
europe ni aux premiers et nous importons
nos pommes depuis le chili l'afrique du
sud où l'argentine c'est à dire que nous
marchons sur la tête c'est la même chose
pour les ordinateurs c'est la même chose
pour les hélicoptères c'est la même
chose pour les chaussures etc etc
alors moi je veux un agriculteur demain
qui vivent non pas des primes mais de
son travail
les américains remettent leurs jachères
en culture moi je veux qu'on fasse la
même chose qu'on établisse la préférence
européenne c'est à dire que les
consommateurs européens consomment les
produits qui sont fabriqués chez nous en
europe par nos entreprises par les
salariés des entreprises européennes si
on fait ça le pays repart le pays revers
[Musique]
je m'appelle christian patrons pêcheurs
artisans depuis quelques années nous
sommes confrontés à des rentrées de
poissons de pays tiers sur notre marché
on a l'impression d'être gouvernés par
des technocrates du parlement européen
et à cause de cela c'est la mort du
métier de pêcheur artisanal et de tous
les métiers artisans de france
encore un exemple typique du chômage
provoquée par le désordre européen avec
un salaire français vous pouvez payer
aujourd'hui 64 années 80 philippe a donc
toutes frontières ouvertes on peut pas
lutter c'est vrai dans toutes les
industries de main d'oeuvre
c'est vrai dans les services dans les
transports et arrière etc moi je propose
de taxer les importations sauvages des
pays à très bas salaires et qui n'ont
pas de protection sociale si on veut
maintenir chez nous les acquis de
civilisation la protection sociale il
faut un minimum de protection économique
[Musique]
je chasse depuis l'âge de 16 ans je
chasse pour mon plaisir
nous sommes les premiers protecteurs de
la nature
on comprend mal les directives de
bruxelles qui nous impose des lois soit
disant que nous sommes pas capables de
gérer notre cheptel
alors que de nous-mêmes l'an passé nous
avons arrêté la chasse au lièvre pour en
favoriser le repeuplement
ce chasseur est certainement beaucoup
plus efficaces pour la protection de la
nature et de nos traditions régionales
que n'importe quel technocrates de
bruxelles
moi je propose non plus un pouvoir qui
s'éloigne mais au contraire un pouvoir
qu'il soit proche des gens proches de
toutes nos préoccupations quotidiennes
il faut que les français soient libres
tout simplement il faut que la france et
c'est la grande question soit une nation
les mains
[Musique]
l'urgence c'est de sortir la france du
socialisme
je suis le seul dont la majorité a
proposé la protection européenne de nos
emplois et la réduction des dépenses des
administrations
l'urgence est de retrouver le sens des
valeurs quand j'entends parler de
distribuer des seringues des jeunes de
15 ans je dis ça suffit
la démagogie je suis le seul à proposer
de lutter contre la corruption et la
drogue pour moi la vie la famille
doivent être protégés contre toutes les
cultures de violence alors la gauche
vous le sentez bien
il a cette fois ci aucune chance de
l'emporter
vous pouvez donc choisir au premier tour
le candidat de vos convictions
aidez moi à donner un maximum de poids à
nos idées pour que le prochain président
de la république fasse une politique de
droite et non de gauche fasse une
politique de la france
ans
[Musique]
on